what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i have a special guest on the
channel
what are you looking at my little sister
eva
before i start
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos also i
got a new mic today so let me know how
the audio sounds
because
this is like new
so i i had to adjust some settings so
let me know in the chat how the audio
sounds
which one are you
actually let me make sure you're on
touch touch your mic
okay you're at mic three okay i just
want to make sure i'm gonna meet the
other two
so hi
how are you
hi are you excited to come on my show
today it's a heart straw yeah look
that's so fun
so
what do you think about my youtube
channel do you hate it
i'm not gonna lie i've never even
watched your video you've never watched
a video of mine no you see my clips
though on tick tock no
i don't actually watch them i like and
pass
sometimes i click the do not show again
what you click the do not show again you
do the same thing to gabrielle it's so
repetitive do you know how many times i
see you people in my 40s i want my
content not yours
so you don't watch any of my content not
really so do you know what my channel is
even about
not really really okay you know it's
about like relationships right yeah no i
i've gathered that much you know you're
not the best
[Music]
um
fair fair point
um
[Music]
okay so
it talks about like have you heard of
the red pill
no so we're talking about like the
matrix but
um
no so the red pill is like
a pill that like men have to swallow
basically and it like it's basically
saying everything they've learned about
dating is like not like what they're
told
so for example like
men are told to like be nice to women
and like like put them on a pedestal
but like girls like [ __ ]
do you think that's true
what depends are you asking are you
asking like gabrielle are you asking you
or you asking like
just in general like
like the [ __ ] usually get more girls
than like super nice guys yeah because
they're more direct about it yeah
yeah no i agree but so that's what they
call it the red pill is just realizing
like everything isn't what they thought
it was and like the disney fairy tale is
just fake
you should do like asmr
[Laughter]
um like another thing that they talk
about
is like
eighty percent of women want twenty
percent of men so they're the reason
and then interesting i think it's so
interesting though
like that stat
yeah
okay so i'm going to ask you questions
now
they want to know what i was like as a
kid oh
well i don't really know that much
because i had like i was born when you
were like
like eight or nine right
i'm 25 you're seven 17
in the chat she's 17
[Applause]
17.
don't be weird
okay
um
yeah and i'm 25 so
so you were like eight yeah yeah and
like by the time i was eight like that's
when i start remembering things when
you're eight so you were like
i was like a teenager
yeah i was a pretty like no you were
such an annoying teenager you always
always had music blasting i would have
to go in your room to turn it off and
you had all of the house phones every
time a phone was oh i did the entire
room was buzzing because the house
phones were in there and then if we ever
needed water bottles we literally just
went to your room to go okay okay but i
i was not a wild teenager
no i think the only person who's been a
wild teenager really is gabrielle and
adam what are you talking about adam
like he threw parties and stuff like
that but he didn't like go out like late
every day night like gabrielle is out
late all the time i threw one party in
high school and i got caught and sent to
wisconsin for a month it didn't go well
[Music]
mom and dad are basically begging me to
throw parties
my answer is no i don't think i have
enough
i don't think i have enough friends to
throw a party anymore
well you don't really need friends you
just need
a place that's open
and has alcohol like
you know what do you know what hypergamy
is
no
the chat if you put questions in the
chat i'll ask eva hypergamy is basically
like girls want to get the best guy that
they can get
don't stop reading the chat
i'm going to put it away if you read the
chat no stop reading the chat
because sometimes the chat's wild and it
does i don't want to distract
no i even i don't want it to distract
from the conversation come on
i like having it there look at out
do you know what hypergamy is i said no
already no so it's basically like
getting the best guy that you can like
attain pretty much like girls always
want
the most they can get for their looks so
it's kind of like look sister girls as
to money is for to men
and so like girls are always looking to
get the best guy they can get basically
so a lot of times like
famous people will slide into normal
girls dms and now those girls think they
can like get commitment from those guys
and they really can't like they're not
on their level those guys just want to
sleep with them
gabriel has like nba players
stop don't put that on
don't don't don't
okay um okay so
next one okay guys stop it
stop with the bot accounts i know i know
who's behind these bot accounts
i know who it is and this is weird
so stop it's the same dude
what that's funny um okay do you know
what the wall is
have you heard about the wall that girls
go through
no the wall is like when a girl hits
like 28 to like 35. i don't know the
period when people are like you're not
useful or like
you're just not as hot as you were like
10 years ago
basically
so that's like when girls start to get
married because they realize their looks
are like starting to run out
it's so bad
you don't think what are you what are
your hobbies
what aren't my hobbies
she's got plants
yeah
i do have that
horses tell them well there's a lot of
things i do because i like knit i sew
when i do like different types of crafts
and i have plants then i have a horse
and we have the dogs and i have school
eva's very creative
she's like my creative little sister
very messy
okay you're messy too i your room last
year was so messy
i'm still a teenager teenagers are
notorious for being messy okay my my
apartment isn't even messy i just spent
two hours cleaning okay i don't know why
you did that because it was grimy i
couldn't deal with it
okay
um
do you like school
no
not high school at least
um average men are invisible to average
women do you think that's true
yeah because people are always trying to
date up even though they can't
[Applause]
eva's kind of red pill aware
do you think i tried to date up in my
last relationship
so not me
no you should have an odd type
what's my type
i'm not gonna put that on
you think he was my normal type
i think you thought he was hot
and he's not stop stop okay okay
um
what do you want to be when you grow up
i'm going into clinical psychology
yeah you'd be a good psychologist
actually right
um
oh i stand by jordan p yeah you're right
actually jordan peterson's definition of
hypergamy that's true
do you who do you think breaks up
relationships more men or women
i think it depends
men ghost more people but women i think
break up with people more often or cause
the man to break up with her you know
what percentage of divorces are
initiated by women
yeah i'm not i'm not surprised that it'd
be more women yeah it's like 70 to 80
percent
and it's 90 if you're college educated
it's 90 so if i get divorced
it's like
most likely my choice
yeah i'm not surprised
do you know that one of the
number one predictors of divorce it's
like i think an 80 or 90 chance of
divorce is if
the girl starts making more money than
her husband not crazy
still not surprised why
because that's one of the things that
society makes a big deal out of that's
really not a big deal money yeah like
who makes more money in a relationship
like the like term who wears the pants
like who cares do you think that um
like
because we grew up with money we don't
care about it
what do you mean like i always say if
i'm like
like looking to date a guy like i don't
really care how much money he has
so do you think because we like grew up
with money we care about it less or do
you think
i definitely think i don't care about
who i'm dating with money but i care
about what job i have with how much
money i make
because like i i've never lived like
that sounds bad but like it's true i've
never lived like broke so i'm scared not
to make money in life
yeah
yeah i mean
i just want to make it i just want to be
able to buy my youtube equipment that's
like the only i don't even really buy
clothes often i've been trying to do a
little better just because i do the show
both of these i just found my closet and
claimed them as mine
i think we're kind of similar where we
spend money on our hobbies versus like
appearance
my hobby is more expensive than yours
horses yeah his boarding month is six
hundred dollars oh yeah you gotta you
gotta start making money money
thanks for the reminder
yeah damn 600 a month that's like a half
an apartment
this apartment's expensive
well it's a nice apartment
do you want a lot of kids
no
do you want any kids sometimes sometimes
you you couldn't not have you're so good
with babies you love kids yeah but i
hate kids
you love them though i i could not see
you not having kids
okay do you think um what do you look
for in like a boyfriend do you wanna
you're kinda young but
do you just wanna be cute
i don't really care about looks i just
want a good personality like funny
yeah and just like actually be able to
have a conversation with them does he
have to be like a hippie too i'm
[Laughter]
she wore hippie pants on the plane guys
they were comfy she i was like is my
sister turning to a hippie
you're a hippie i don't think so i'd be
a good hippie though i'd be a good drug
dealer too
i don't honestly don't think you'd be a
good drug dealer i think you would speak
like i think
you'd come up to like you that you'd use
it on youtube guys guess what i'm a
dream
yeah but i would have such good customer
service but you would do like how i got
into drug dealing
you know what i was saying like if i
let's say i don't ever get married okay
i would do a youtube channel called like
like a single one single old like
old maid reacts and that's going to
single and childless woman react
sell your eggs
my eggs why so much money doing that i
know but like in their health
repercussions like don't i only have so
many eggs well yeah you get early
menopause but like who cares
me i don't want early menopause
we already do it very late in our life
anyways yeah but
like i'd want to pro
do that later what you sell your eggs
i'm going to i'm not 18 yet really yeah
why i have to sign up to be a bone
marrow donor
but you don't get paid for that that's
just like to help somebody okay well
you're a better person than me i heard
that [ __ ] hurts
so oh my god like so you want to give up
you're going to give up your egg that's
like the most i could never i could not
you'll make like six thousand dollars
doing it
and also depends on how much you have
but with our family like
send super chats guys
so i don't have to sell my ex
i'd make more money
why do people want
white women with red hair
gingers yeah
everybody wants a red hair but i can't
get it really
people make fun of gingers i know but
they still want red hair um do you how
many like random people on the internet
have told me that they love my hair
color because it's really hard to dye
your hair you have the prettiest hair
color in our family in my opinion like i
think you have the actually the
prettiest like shade of red
when do you think it's the ideal age to
get married
like when do you want to get married
like 26 27. um
that's like
i wish i was already married
you married is scary hannah be married
and married is scary but i think austin
i bet soon oh no melissa's gonna leave
him if he doesn't do it soon
yeah especially now that greg is married
like
yeah the clock is ticking austin i hope
he does she's great so
i like
[Music]
i want i hope that happens soon
um
what else do you want to talk about
what is it like
having
like a family so big did you enjoy
having so many siblings
no really
there's too many
i really liked it like i wouldn't trade
it for anything but when i was your age
i think i might have had a different
answer i don't think i would have traded
it for anything like i don't want a
smaller family but i did there were
definitely aspects i didn't like
lack of attention
um i mean i guess
i'd say no i did i actually liked not
having a lot of attention but when i was
younger i probably would have liked more
like now like i'm glad i didn't but like
i think that because i didn't have
attention i didn't want it i
think that that's why we're all funny
[Music]
i think it's because dad turns
everything into a joke
no but i'm saying like i feel like to
get attention like in the family you had
to be funny and so everyone in the
family is funny and entertaining
that's awful
is it true i didn't say it was wrong
i think that's also why we're all like
involved in a million things because mom
and dad like
i i always felt like we're more proud of
me and like everyone when we were like
doing something cool so like
like whatever sport it was or maybe
horseback riding for you mom and dad
were not happy i did horseback riding
really they were really mad about it
they wanted they tried to talk me out of
it for years really was it because it
was such an expensive sport no it was
because they didn't the mom didn't
consider it a sport oh really i'm like
mom i've fallen off a horse so many
times like that it sounds actually
pleasant i wouldn't continue doing it if
i
like when i fell off of nico like the
day before christmas eve i literally
couldn't walk i that sounds awful i'm
afraid of horses kind of i know you
could see girl with horses the first
time she's met nico she i opened a stall
door for her to like pet him and she
stood out there like poking him for an
hour
wait okay what about um
what someone asked what was your
favorite family vacation growing up
does it have to be family
i really liked when i went to germany by
myself
[Laughter]
well you visited nannies right
i'm assuming um i went with natalie like
the first time i went by myself i went
to
natalie and then i went to i think it
was like katrina or someone like that
i think
i think that
family vacations are always have like
highs and lows
would you agree with that
oh yeah like like i would say like some
of our family vacations were so fun like
certain moments like do you remember
when we went to india and like we were
in i think dubai on the way there and we
were all playing that like tournament
you remember
no i remember dubai i remember that all
of you were foolish when we went to no
way it was
wait it was abu dhabi that's what it was
when we did that tournament and that
penthouse
yeah that was so fun
no but i just remember being in that
house and all and there was definitely
dubai because we went to the world's
telescope oh was it
out of the window okay okay but i
remember all of you were foolish because
on our way there we stopped to get
subway
and you guys were so excited that they
had ice
so everybody got ice and i was like i'm
not drinking that that seems like a risk
so i got like a bottled drink and then
the next day when all of you were puking
because the indian ice was not like
filtered to like the american standards
when all of you were puking i was
running up and stare up and down the
stairs
because all you foolish people got sick
um
yeah that was i was so mad i missed the
camel back riding i still never got to
do that
and
yeah i was 18 i think so
it's like a missed opportunity because i
was sick
you were right
i also really liked um a couple florida
vacations i think were really fun i'm so
sick of florida
you must go there all the time they
didn't go there as much when i was a kid
well it's just we have a house there and
have a lake i love the house there
though yeah but how often do you go
there
a couple times a year like
last december i went there four times in
december okay in like four separate
vacations not like four days
what would you say is your best
childhood memory
i really liked the forts we used to
build that was fun oh those were so fun
it would make it like the entire
basement
oh my gosh i wha what is your favorite
memory with me
i know there's so many to choose from
you can't pick
so
many um
next question what
why would you answer
you can't think of one no like one time
we hung out and it was fun
now the moment i want to bring up i'm
not going to put on the internet
but it wasn't fun for me
i can text it to you
text it to me
text it to me
i don't know
where is she
i'm like what
what is i'm so nosy like what is it
i still don't know what you were talking
about
oh wait i did
i was at portillo's yeah we were seeing
the portillo's drive-thru after he
picked me up from volleyball okay yeah
we're not
we're not gonna tell that story
um okay
it's like the only time i remember you
in my childhood
that's it we hung out a lot
i remember the time that me and gabriel
were fighting and you pulled me off of
gabrielle
i took you on girls nights you don't
remember that i'd take you guys like
rollerblading you and amelia
you don't remember that no yeah i'd like
we would do movie nights like i would do
it in the theater
so i did all that for nothing
um yeah pretty much wow
um what are you the most thankful for
um
like in the future or currently
currently
honestly that mom and dad are paying for
my college
yeah it's a good one
sometimes like because mom and dad were
gone a lot growing up
and sometimes if i'm ever like when i
used to like get mad or like be upset
about it i'd be like you know what my
friends have a lot of college dads
and i can hang out with my parents all i
want now
i'm taking a class right now she was
like yeah we're gonna calculate how much
debt you have in college and i literally
had to raise my hand be like i don't
know i don't think i'm gonna have debt
and she's like oh you probably will like
i'm not
the people like must be nice it is
[Music]
it really is
i'm looking at all my friends and like
every single one of you taking out a
student loan this year
not me
um okay what is something you wish more
people understood about you in the
family
though we're not snobs just because we
have money no we're like the most down
down-to-earth people ever that's what i
get told by a lot of my friends too is
that like we don't act like we have
money
like like because we don't
like we have money but we don't like
like we don't flex it with everything we
do and you know what's funny this
comment someone left in our channel was
like y'all are rich but you look bro
because we do like
i don't get my hair done for fun the
last time i got my hair done
professionally was like fifth grade no
same and same with like nails like i
don't i actually do my nails recently
but that's because and i use my own
money too it's not like mom and dad the
only one who looks bougie is gabrielle
that's just because gabrielle spends way
too much money on clothes
that's her thing i spend money on
everyone is something they spend money
on mine's just youtube equipment
yeah but like it's just like i don't
know we don't do things that rich people
do like i'm sure we have the money too
because we have a cheap dad
like i remember being like we were the
richest set of all my friends growing up
and i remember like being like we never
eat out i was so jealous of all my
friends that got to eat out and fly
because we we never now we do now but
like we drove everywhere everywhere
we drove to washington
we drive to colorado like every summer
oh my god
like literally
and so but i feel like because we grew
up with like a cheap dad that's like why
we're not snooty you know what i mean i
also think it's because both of our
parents didn't have money growing up so
like yeah like they were frugal with it
no matter what because they weren't used
to having it
no i i agree um what is something i
don't know about you
[Music]
i don't know
i mean there's a lot but there's not a
lot i want to say what what does that
mean
are you are you up to shenanigans i mean
always but what shenanigans have you
been up to
i actually don't think i'm a fanny
shenanigans is this the hippie stuff oh
my gosh
who got in the most trouble
adam i'm in between me and you i think
you
okay i don't actually do anything mom
and dad just hate me sometimes
i don't know i cuz i got a lot in a lot
of trouble the one party i threw yeah
but i got yelled at the other day
because amelia didn't go to soccer
practice i'm like how am i supposed like
you guys are the ones picking her up
i was like
i was just my problem look i don't i
couldn't tell you
um giordano's are illuminati's i like
giordano's yeah i think geode i've never
really had like i've had it a few times
but
um
what's your favorite food
um
probably sushi mine too see she's so
good she's so good i think that we
should we should get sushi in london
this weekend i should make pokeballs
because i've really been wanting a
pokeball and then you bought that sushi
but you need to find a place that has
actual sushi grade salmon
no you probably have a parasite in you i
don't i no i would freeze it first
you freeze it for like a week and then
it's fine
no
oh well
i might have embarrassed it the only way
to get rid of it
is to cook it well how do i know if i
got one wouldn't i feel it you can live
with parasites for years without knowing
it oh that's why my mom's like freaking
out saying that she hasn't she doesn't
but that's why she's speaking she has
one
okay
if you could choose one superpower
what would it be
like anything is there a list anything
probably invisibility honestly like
imagine how fun that'd be like you could
sneak anywhere nobody would notice
i think i would pick
like incredibly smart because then i
could figure everything out yeah but if
you were invisible you could literally
just go sneaking at the answers to a
test and then go take the test yeah but
like what a second good is that going to
do me at 25.
we do papers
i feel like that's not superpower that's
just an ability
superpowers are like flaming
invisibility like things are actually
non-feasible
um i'm gonna drop some let me think of
some red pill guys what red pill
knowledge should i drop on her
some truths
some red pill truths
there's 45 people in the chat right now
they're kind of wild
what's evil's favorite celebrity what's
your favorite song
i don't actually have a favorite
celebrity i'm not gonna lie
i don't have a favorite song right now
but i have one that i'm obsessed with
for some reason
fast car yeah that's my favorite song
i'm not my favorite song but i'm just
obsessed with it right now oh my god
that's so funny that you like because
i've never showed you that song
but that's literally like one of my i
learned it on the guitar did you go to
kairos
yeah
how was that for you oh my god you guys
do you know what kairos okay let me i'm
gonna tell the chat it's like a catholic
retreat thing
um
mom told me it was gonna be like
life-changing and stuff but it really
wasn't for me
i just like went there and then people
would like cry
did you cry because everybody was crying
everyone was so confused no
i was i was chilling i was like it was
fun but i'm like why can't i have my
phone i was irritated oh i gave them a
fake phone and kept mine oh really yeah
i'm smarter not harder people like well
i don't think i gave them i don't think
they took our phones it was just like
they were you guys probably didn't
everybody have phones at the time
because it was like i'm not that old
like everyone had cell phones pretty
much
i'm not that
old i hated kairos so much that was
actually an awful experience
and then they they tried to do this
thing that was really weird because like
my school didn't do like one of like the
program kyros they did like they made
their own
and they got like like status in the
chapel and handed us baby pictures of
ourselves which first off mom sent them
a picture of gabrielle so that was to
start off to a great weekend oh and did
i send you a letter
i think so i think i did
i don't know i don't even get like a
thank you come on
okay
they gave us these like these like
pictures of our like baby pictures of
ourselves and they sat us in the chapel
and they were like look at these perfect
little girls you once were you want to
get back to being that perfect little
girl i'm like how am i not perfect now
[Music]
like then like it made it even worse i
was holding a picture of gabrielle i was
like
it was like mom
she said the wrong kid
it was gabriella's like first birthday
like photo shoot like the one with the k
and i'm like this isn't even me like
this is very clearly gabrielle the
audacity
it's not even like it was a baby baby
pictures like a one-year-old i'm like
this very clearly is gabrielle
what what is your favorite family
tradition
traditions do we even have i like pics
with santa
i think that one's funny it's just so
tedious and annoying
i don't actually know what other
traditions we have that are like
we're not a very tradition filled family
yes we have so many true momma kill you
right now the freaking nutcrackers are
christmas traditions the valentine's day
when mom makes breakfast and the whole
family gets together
like fourth of july when we all like
i feel like those aren't like traditions
or just things other other families
don't do [ __ ] like that eva
families don't have 10 kids
okay i like the christmas tradition or
the
yearly tradition of adding a new kid
[Laughter]
well they stopped for a couple years
um wait you know what do you know what
alpha and beta is i want you they want
me to explain to you alpha and beta i
know the terms i don't know actually
what it is
ellie's being so freaking annoying i've
learned to tune her out
i still live with it i wonder if the
chat can hear ellie
i don't know but um
what was i talking about
oh alpha and beta basically like there's
guys that girls view as relationship
material and those are betas
and that's like protection and
provisioning and alpha is like
it's not touch screen hun
please open it back up i was having fun
i'll open it in a second i'm gonna
explain this to you then i'll open it
um and then alpha is like
the guy that's like hot basically and
like a leader
so the alpha is usually like
girls will sleep with faster and the
bettas
they'll girls will make weight
did i explain that right guys
did i explain that right
um
i can't hear ellie i didn't think so
these these mics don't pick up like they
just pick up right in front of you
um do you agree do you agree on gender
roles
do you think mom and dad had gender
roles
i think mama not real like in some
aspects yes like dad would never cook
dinner but like mom was a ceo so
yeah that's what i was thinking that she
sorta did like there were certain
aspects but for the most part no
because they were both kind of doing
like they were working in the same
company and she worked a lot but she
also was the only one that did laundry
and like cooked and stuff yeah other
than i think that they the gender roles
were very apparent with the au pairs we
had though oh yeah with the nannies oh
my gosh i
when i was a teenager i had the worst
nannies i hope none of them see this but
they were so i like hated the nannies i
had when i was a teenager
when i was younger i had like kathleen
and like
the ones i liked the older ones oh my
god
you had good nannies i think
well except for hannah the one that like
left because her boyfriend like her
fiance broke up with her
she left after like a month and a half
she was so mean i actually hated her so
much
and she like gave me her like german
phone number or whatever it was like go
text him like i'm never gonna text you
like you're not going to receive a high
the chat says alpha is an f boy beta is
the human atm without a spine
it's kind of like when guys are super
nice to girls it doesn't make us like
attracted to them
yeah
you agree with that
sometimes depends on the guy
but yeah
i think that's i think other people are
coming soon so i'm probably going to end
the stream
but
this is fun
thanks for you know coming on the chat
appreciate you you're going to come on
the stream later
you don't want to talk about trans women
in sports
not really no a little too controversial
for you yeah a little bit
eva eva's our token liberal of the
family
how do you know i'm the only one you
don't know that
amelia
i don't know i mean i don't know
token um
i'd say i'd say we probably have more
than one i'm just giving you [ __ ]
you know what's funny everyone on my
tick tock is commenting like
she's just like this because of her
breakup like
i'm like anyone in my family would tell
you that i've taught these things my
whole life it's kind of annoying yeah
like non-political people they're like
shut the f up
[Laughter]
[Music]
um okay guys
um subscribe okay and come back in like
45 minutes we're going live again we're
gonna be talking about like trans women
in sports
so
thanks